Oh Leute, ich habe mir gedacht, heute Abend kein Kreiselgrind und wenn heute Abend kein Kreiselgrind, dann kann ich einfach mal den Stream anmachen, ohne dass ich mir großartig was im Vorfeld überlegt habe.
Ich muss ja seit der Woche wieder arbeiten, das ist geistig echt anstrengend, nicht weil es die Woche so viel zu machen gibt, sondern einfach die Umstellung von ganzen Tag Kreiselgrind zu man muss wieder was machen für sein Geld.
Ich hätte kein Problem damit 24-7 MMO Kreiselgrind zu machen und dafür bezahlt zu werden.
Also im gleichen Umfang wie jetzt.
Null Viewer, aber mindestens 5, 6.
Das schwankt immer, das ist sehr weird auf Twitch teilweise.
Und manchmal dauert es auch ein paar Minuten bis tatsächlich Notifications und so verschickt werden, aber da bin ich schon dran gewöhnt.
Und ähnlich habe ich auch ein bisschen.
Seit gestern Abend habe ich auch ein bisschen Kopfweh.
Ich hoffe nicht, dass ich ernsthaft mich am ersten Tag in Frankfurt gleich mit Corona oder irgendeinem Kack wieder angesteckt habe.
Das hatte ich einmal, das brauche ich nicht wieder.
Das war richtig Kacke, da war ich drei Wochen im Arsch.
Sadge.
Wie war die erste Woche?
Die ist ja noch nicht rum.
Die ist ja noch nicht rum, aber bis jetzt war ganz okay.
War nicht viel los.
War nicht, war nicht viel los.
Wie war bei euch die erste Woche?
Also es war nicht viel los.
Wie gesagt, ich habe nur festgestellt, ich habe komplett verlernt mit Leuten zu reden, nachdem ich jetzt einen Monat Kreiselgrind gemacht habe.
Sind meine Social Skills noch schlechter als vorher schon.
Wir haben irgendwann Ende des Monats ein Team-Event Neujahrsessen.
Da muss ich noch gucken, wie ich das am besten absage.
Das ist mir zu spät.
Und außerdem habe ich auf abendliche Team-Events irgendwie auch keinen Bock.
Kennt mich, bin ich so social.
Ich will lieber MMO-Kreiselgrind machen.
Verstehe mich mit den Leuten gut, daran liegt es nicht.
Ich habe trotzdem keinen Bock.
1 bis 21 Uhr an einem Mittwoch oder so sogar.
Mittwoch 21 Uhr in Frankfurt.
Nee, das ist nix.
Mittagessen würdest du mit mir reden lassen?
Mr. SN Alive.
Danke schön für den Sub.
Pog.
Wer braucht schon Social Skills?
Ja, ich glücklicherweise nicht so viel.
Ah nee, ich finde das nicht schlimm.
Ich habe aber gemerkt, dass ich...
Moment, warte mal.
Ich mache mal kurz hier andere Musik an.
Nee, ich mache mal die VM an und Package Updates.
Was wollte ich jetzt gerade sagen?
Das...
Achso, ja.
Gut, ich habe gemerkt, dass ich mich, egal wie man es dreht und wendet,
einfach im Office selbst nicht so gut konzentrieren kann wie daheim.
Gar nicht so sehr, dass man sich da vorne nehmen würde.
Ich mache jetzt nix.
Sondern man kann sich einfach nicht so gut konzentrieren.
Da hast du irgendwelche Leute, die telefonieren.
Irgendwelche Leute, die dich fragen.
Sei es, dass du selbst irgendwo mal irgendwie so dein Ohr dran hängen willst oder so.
Deswegen mag ich persönlich auch Wechselarbeitsplätze.
Ich sitze ja lieber auf Wechselarbeitsplätzen als am eigentlichen Platz.
Im Büro.
Da bin ich auch ab und zu mal.
Aber da weiß ich, wenn da irgendjemand telefoniert, ist nix, was man irgendwas mitkriegen muss.
Ich finde es auch im eigenen Teambüro immer ein bisschen doof,
da Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörer anzuhaben.
Da kriegt man nix von mit.
Also mir ist...
Außerdem gefällt mir das mit dem Schreibtisch viel besser an Wechselarbeitsplätzen.
Ich mag Wechselarbeitsplätze.
Das ist ja ein Angestell für den Sub.
Ich finde das nice.
Ich war da...
Ich war am Dienstag wieder in Frankfurt bei der Versicherung.
Hab mich an den Wechselarbeitsplatz gehockt.
Zeug aufgebaut.
Mittags alles für den Rucksack geschmissen und abgehauen.
Perfekt.
Und irgendwie...
Weiß nicht.
Irgendwie gibt es wenige Leute, die Wechselarbeitsplätze mögen.
Da war...
Gut, das war auch der zweite Erste.
Am zweiten Ersten war natürlich nicht viel los.
Aber...
Da war halt sehr ruhig auch.
Warum gibt es Whoop Arrive nicht mehr?
Ne, gibt es doch.
Der hat bei mir nur das E-Mode nicht mehr.
Wieso wenig Updates nur?
Was ist da los?
Ich habe drei Tage oder so nicht mehr geupdatet.
Anzeige ist raus.
Übrigens, Google ist ja auch wieder...
Ist ja wieder der Held.
Google hat wieder Zeug umbenannt.
By the way, ich zeige euch das mal.
Falls ihr damit Probleme habt.
Google...
Google Cloud CLI SDK.
Die haben ihre Packages umbenannt.
Tja, findet man jetzt hier nicht
Zumindest
Es gab ein Package
Das nannte sich
Google Cloud SDK
So, das gibt es jetzt nicht mehr
Es gibt jetzt das gleiche Package, nur anderer Name
Google Cloud CLI
Und die Dependencies haben sich geändert
Aber die alten Packages
Die sind dann nicht weg
Du wunderst dich auf einmal beim Updaten, warum du irgendwelche
File-Konflikte kriegst in deinem File-Manager
Was Google da teilweise wieder für Dinger macht
Ist echt super weird
Renamed
Hier, we have renamed our set of
Command Line Developer Tools
Google CLI
Das heißt jetzt
Nicht mehr
Cloud SDK, sondern Cloud CLI
Alles klar
Man konnte das natürlich auch nicht unter gleichem Namen lassen
Obviously
Wäre ja ein Unding, wenn das einfach weiterhin
Google Cloud SDK heißen würde
Ja, stimmt, stimmt
Ja, das war die Woche eh das Beste
Auf jedem Meeting, überall
Haben sie sich
Wo ist Neues und wie seid ihr gerutscht?
Und sich wieder alle gefreut
Ich meine
Die meisten Leute meinen das nett
Die wissen ja nicht, dass ich so ein unsozialer
Kackspaß bin
Den das nervt, wenn die Leute nett sein wollen
Diese Leute wollen ja nett sein
Ich versuche dann auch immer nett zu sein
Letztens
Fand ich witzig
Ähm
Habe ich
Hatten wir es von Teilzeit arbeiten
Und da habe ich halt gemeint
So, ich mache das jetzt, glaube ich, schon 2013 oder so
Und ich kann das echt nur empfehlen
Und da wurde ich dann gefragt
Ähm, ja, warum ich Teilzeit arbeiten würde
Wegen den Kindern oder warum
Ich meine, ne, ich habe mich noch nicht weiter
Ich habe mich noch nicht
Geforkt
Ich habe mich noch nicht fortgepflanzt
Nicht wegen der Kinder
So
Ich sehe wahrscheinlich mittlerweile echt so
Dad-mäßig aus vom Alter her
So Vater-mäßig aus
Auch vom Alter her
Und allem
Vielen Dank für den Sub
Gamepad auch am Start
Der schmale Access Point
Danke Leute für die ganzen Subs
Nee, nicht wegen den Kindern
Deswegen habe ich keine Teilzeit angefangen
Ihr wisst warum
Ihr seid ein Teil davon
Weshalb ich mit
Unbewusst, weshalb ich mit Teilzeit angefangen habe
Eigentlich benutze ich den aktuellen Sub
Eher zum Abgammeln
Noch einen Tag weiter
Anstatt, dass ich ernsthaft was für YouTube und Twitch machen würde
Aber so ist es halt
So muss es sein
Ich meine, warum nicht
Ich finde das vollkommen in Ordnung
Ich würde es auch nicht an die große Glocke hängen
Jetzt kommen wir noch auf die Idee, mich nicht einzustellen
Das sind ja zwei Fragen in einem
Also
Das ist eine schwierige Frage
Also den ersten Teil der Frage kann ich einfach beantworten
Nee, habe ich nicht
Den zweiten Teil der Frage
Kann ich einfach beantworten?
Der ist in der Tat enorm schwierig zu beantworten
Denn
Ihr habt ja so die ein oder anderen Sachen im Stream schon mitgekriegt
Und in
99% der Fälle
Ist es ja immer daran gescheitert
Weil ich mich um nichts gekümmert habe
Ihr kennt ja die ein oder andere Story
Also
Und ihr kennt mich mittlerweile auch
Für mich sind
Soziale Interaktionen
Immer sehr
Einigermaßen
Belastend ist das falsche Wort
Anstrengend
Und das führt meistens dazu
Dass wenn sich etwas anbahnt
Beziehungsweise anbahnen könnte
Ich das direkt versuche zu vermeiden
So und
Das läuft dann auf so Dinge raus
Wie erinnert sich noch einer an das Weihnachtsgrill
Von vor
Boah, wann war das?
Das war noch vor Corona
Wo ich euch das mal erzählt habe, ne?
Wo wir uns sogar schon kleine Sachen zu Weihnachten geschenkt haben
Was man ja nicht einfach random macht
Und was habe ich gemacht?
Ich habe mir sogar was nettes zum Weihnachtsgeschenk überlegt
Da hat sich auch super drüber gefreut
Und was habe ich gemacht?
Ich habe mich nie wieder gemeldet
Einfach random
Ich habe nie wieder
Und alles
Immer umschifft so
Weil ich halt sozial mäßig der übelste Kackspaß bin
Ich habe euch das ja schon erzählt
Also
Es ist
Ja, ist halt so
Jetzt
Nach vier Jahren ist klar
Ey, übrigens, vor vier Jahren, ne?
Aber ne, mache ich nicht
Weil es hat ja seinen Grund gehabt
Vier Jahre, nicht vier Monate, vier Wochen
Vier Jahre
Das ist das, was ich euch erzählt hatte damals
Mit den Schuhen
Vielleicht erinnert ihr euch noch
Ich meine
Ich meine, ich habe mich nicht mehr so gut verstanden
Ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass das Zeug, was ich hier blödes Zeug labere
Sich überhaupt noch irgendjemand daran erinnert
Nach vier Jahren
Wo ich das sage, mit den Schuhen
Bist du damit ein...
Ja, ich bin unglücklich, wenn ich viele soziale Kontakte habe
Das ist es ja
Ich weiß nicht, das ist bestimmt irgendeine Krankheit
Oder so, keine Ahnung
Wahrscheinlich
Wahrscheinlich ist das
Irgendwer hat irgendeinen super komplizierten lateinischen Namen
Oder so
Ja
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein
Nein, habe ich nicht
Also ganz so schlimm war das jetzt auch nicht
Also ich habe ja nicht einfach
Ich habe ja nicht einfach
So nach dem Motto
Ah, guck mal eine Message
Ach, löschen und nicht mal
Nein, nein, nein, ich habe aber nichts in der Richtung mehr unternommen
So
Ich habe nicht wirklich geantwortet von mir
Also mit irgendwelchen
Ja
Weiteren Versuchen
Im Prinzip war ich happy, dass sie sich darüber gefreut hat
Und wisst ihr
Ich meine, ihr müsst euch mal überlegen, ja
Wenn eine Frau
Einem ein Vera-Torx-Schraubendreher-Set schenkt
Das ist eigentlich schon ein sehr positives Signal
Also, dass sie schon Plan hat, ja
Random Leute, die keine Ahnung haben
Schenken irgendein komisches Zeugs vom Aldi oder so
Ein Vera-Torx-Schraubendreher-Set
Das habe ich übrigens immer noch hier am Start
Und ich habe ihr ein paar Schuhe geschenkt
Weil, weil
Mädels haben ja immer kalte Füße und so
Und dann
Ich habe ihr ein paar Schuhe geschenkt
Mit so
Was ist da drin?
So Lavendel-Mischung oder so
Die kann man in die Mikrowelle
Die kann man in die Mikrowelle legen
Und dann werden die warm
Und dann hat man irgendwie 45 Minuten warme Füße oder sowas
Ja
Das dachte ich mir schon, dass das gut ankommt
Und
Kam auch gut an
Ja
Und ich kann das nicht erklären
Das ist ganz merkwürdig
Sobald ich merke
Nicht immer
Aber
Sobald ich merke, dass es auf
Real-Life soziale Interaktion rausläuft
Versuche ich das immer zu umgehen
Och
Was jetzt?
Wo da vorn?
Was?
Oh fuck
Was war das letzte was ihr gehört habt?
Also ich habe im Endeffekt nur gesagt
Sobald es
Sobald es auf
Real-Life Interaktion
Auf Real-Life Interaktion rausgeht
Auf
Auf soziale Real-Life Interaktion
Rausläuft
Dann versuche ich das immer zu umgehen
Irgendwie zu vermeiden
Und
Das ist nicht so, dass ich nicht mit Leuten gut klar kommen würde
Ich glaube
Ich glaube die meisten Leute
Mit denen ich mich so
Die finden das
Ich denke nicht, dass sie denken ich bin der übelste Depp
Oder so
Ich glaube die meisten Leute finden mich da ganz nett
Aber ich habe halt so null Interesse an großartigen Socials
Außer mit ein paar Leuten
Mit ein paar Leuten muss ich sagen
Verstehe ich mich echt gut mit denen
Da rede ich auch gerne und viel
Aber es gibt halt nicht so viele
Ja
Auf der alten Arbeit hatte ich so eins, zwei
Mit denen ich öfters geschwätzt habe
Auf der neuen Arbeit habe ich auch so eins, zwei
Mit denen ich öfters schwätze
Privat kenne ich auch so eins, zwei
Das reicht aber
Das ist dann schon komplett ausreichend für mich
Was mich an
Menschenansammlungen stört ist
Also ich habe kein Problem irgendwie
Auf eine Messe zu gehen oder sonst was
Keiner von mir
Der hat ja so richtige
Wie nennt man das so
Menschenansammlungssozialphobie oder sowas
Und der meint
Der fängt immer voll an zu schwitzen
Der wird nervös
Das Problem habe ich nicht
Mich nerven nicht große Menschenansammlungen
Mich nerven
Große Gesprächsrunden
Wo
Es
Darum geht, dass jeder
Jetzt möglichst penetrant erzählen muss
Warum er der tollste
In der Runde ist
Wisst ihr wie ich mein
Das ist ja so ein
Gibt es bestimmt einen Namen für
Ein gewisses soziales Phänomen
Ist das ja
Wenn da mehrere Leute auf dem Haufen stehen
Und am besten auch wenn die sich noch
Nur so am Rande kennen
Da muss jeder erstmal loslassen
Warum er der geilste ist
Und dann kommt der nächste wieder an
Und erzählt warum er der geilste ist
Und wer ist denn da überhaupt dabei
Es interessiert mich überhaupt nicht
Also so sieht es aus
Also wie gesagt
Um das abschließend zu beantworten
Ich bin
Ich bin happy damit
Umso mehr soziale Kontakte ich habe
Umso unglücklicher bin ich
Also insofern ist alles gut
Der Twitch Chat zählt zum Glück nicht als sozialer Kontakt
Ja und auf die Sache
Hier nochmal zurück zu kommen mit 4 Jahren
Ja
Da muss ich jetzt auch nicht mehr
Das ist ja sein Grund
Das wäre jetzt auch nicht realistisch betrachtet
Wäre das jetzt auch nicht anders
Es hat ja seinen Grund gehabt
Es ist nicht so dass ich mich damals gar nicht mehr gemeldet habe
Aber ich habe also überhaupt keine Anstalten mehr gemacht
Das irgendwie weiter zu verfolgen
Ja
Ich habe dann immer nur kurz darauf geantwortet
Wahrscheinlich hat sie dann darauf gewartet
Dass ich mich dann auch mal rühre
Und sowas
Und das ist dann so immer so
Wo man sich am Anfang
Da öfter
Das nochmal geschrieben hat
War jetzt dann halt immer weniger
Und irgendwie so nach 1-2 Wochen gar nicht mehr
Und ich habe dann auch nicht mehr geschrieben
Also insofern
Zumindest eine Sache werde ich nie wieder machen
Das kann ich euch sagen
Das habe ich durch
Keine Mädels mehr in MMOs kennenlernen
Haha das ist vorbei Leute
Das mache ich nicht mehr
Ich kann mich noch daran erinnern
Zu meiner MMO Crying Zeit
Von keine Ahnung
Bis 2007 oder so
Das war so anstrengend
Ja
Ich habe damals
Geht es um die Festival Mädels
Nein um die geht es nicht
Also Mädels rein online
Ist nichts für mich
Also wirklich nur die Leute
Rein online kennenlernen
Und sich da irgendwie dann ein paar Wochen nur schreiben
Und so
Man sieht sich immer von den anderen Leuten was aus
Was sie gar nicht sind
Das ist echt das Problem
Also wenn man
Ich meine ich bin ja realistisch
Im Jahr 2024
Ist es vollkommen normal
Das man Leute online kennen lernt
Und
Das sagen wir mal so
Das die Findung und die Kontaktaufnahme
So untereinander suchen
Dass das online ist keine Frage
Aber
Wenn du die Leute online kennenlernst
Das heißt in einem Game oder irgendeine App
Oder irgendeine Plattform
Und wenn du dir dann wirklich nur Wochen und Monate schreibst
Da kommt nichts bei rum
Da kommt echt nichts bei rum
Also ich habe da nur negative
Erfahrungen mitgemacht
Selbst wenn man ab und zu telefoniert
Und dann sagt oh ja komm lass uns da mal irgendwie
In zwei Monaten bin ich dann in der Nähe
Das bringt nichts Leute
Das habe ich alles schon durch
Das ist voll fürn Arsch
Man muss den Leuten schon mal
Relativ zeitnah über den Weg laufen
Damit man gleich mal abchecken kann
Ob das denn theoretisch
Nicht nur
Fantasiegebilde sind
Die man sich da so zurecht tippt
Oder ob das wirklich ein bisschen
Selbst
Selbst wenn man sich online super versteht
Miteinander telefoniert
Sich in der Webcam schon gesehen hat
Bilder und man sich dann auch gegenseitig
Ganz hübsch findet und passt alles
Es ist echt ein Unterschied wenn man die Leute vor Ort sieht
Ich rede jetzt nicht
Von gefakten Instagram Bildern
Es ist einfach ein Unterschied
Es gibt Leute da denkt man sich ey die sind ganz nett
Den läufst du offline über den Weg
Und denkst dir boah ey
Mit dem oder der halte ich aber
Keine 20 Minuten zusammen
Hier im Raum aus
Das ist Kacke
Das funktioniert nicht
Man muss sich da schon relativ zeitnah
Sich was überlegen
Und wenn das dann so läuft
Dass man sich denkt okay
Man findet sich auch offline ganz sympathisch
Dann ist das ja gut
Aber rein online
Ne das kann es klingen
Ja
Ne aber wie gesagt nicht Festival
Gut wie dem auch sei
Komplett random Thema ich weiß
Hattest du mal eine Frage mit deiner Jugend
Beantwortet oder war da genau
Das Internet weg
Welche Frage meine Jugend
Achso hier das habe ich gar nicht gesehen
Was ist das aus
Ich muss mal kurz die Musik umschalten
Das war eigentlich nur fürs Intro gedacht
Das läuft jetzt zum fünften Mal oder so schon durch
Aber irgendwie was haben wir denn sonst noch
Hier irgendwie
Ja hier wupp wupp wupp perfekt
Also
Die Akte ApoRed
Lügenstrafte Terrorfinanzierung
Jetzt auch noch
Der lässt aber nix aus oder
Oder ist das einfach nur
Chebaited Überschrift
Okay aber zu deiner Frage Profi Harzer
Da frage ich dich auch mal vorher
Ist der Name Programm
Oder einfach nur just for fun
Warst du in deiner Jugend auch so
Und hattest du damals
Vielleicht noch mehr das dich zu verstehen
Ja hatte ich
Also ich war schon
Schon
Eigentlich immer so
Aber das
Ja das hatte ich
Da habe ich sogar mal ein Video zu gemacht glaube ich
Ja also ich hatte
Relativ lange
Das Bedürfnis so
Sachen zu machen
Wie zum Beispiel auf die Weihnachtsfeier gehen
Und oder
Irgendwie
Zu irgendwelchen Veranstaltungen oder sowas
Und ich hatte damals schon keinen Bock
Aber ich bin dann hin weil ich mir immer gedacht habe
Ja so es sieht doch doof aus
Oder das
Gehört sich doch dahin zu gehen und sowas
Oder auch versucht habe irgendwie bisschen mit
Leuten die mir eigentlich am Arsch vorbeigehen zu smalltalken
Und sowas ja ja das habe ich relativ lang probiert
Ja das habe ich relativ lang versucht
Und habe mir eigentlich
Nix ich habe mir da gar nichts großartig bei gedacht
Ich dachte mir eigentlich
Das ist für alle so anstrengend
Wisst ihr wie ich meine
So nach dem Motto
Ich habe eigentlich gedacht es geht allen so
Aber irgendwann habe ich
Irgendwann bin ich aber auf die Idee gekommen
Also wenn das wirklich allen so gehen würde
Dann würde das ja
Wird das ja alles nicht funktionieren
Da würde ja keiner anfangen von sich aus
Ja also das habe ich probiert
Bis Geburtstag bis sonstwas
Also ist eigentlich schon sehr lang
Also in meiner Jugend war das auf jeden Fall
Wo ich noch viel kleiner war
War es noch nicht ganz so schlimm
Zwei Jahre da war ich auch
Ich war bei den Pfadfindern im Verein und sowas
Da ging das eigentlich noch gar nicht
Aber selbst da habe ich schon gemerkt
Dass ich relativ wenig Bock drauf hatte
Auf größere soziale Sachen
Tja keine Ahnung
Psychologie
Was Neurowissenschaftler Psychologie
Solange du keinen Leidensdruck verspürst
Dann hast du keine Krankheit
Na gut Krankheit nicht
Aber es gibt da bestimmt irgendeine Bezeichnung für
Ich bin ja nicht der einzige der da so drauf ist
Es gibt aber so ein paar widersprüchliche Sachen
Ja das muss ich jetzt auch mal sagen
Also
Kein Bock
Auf soziale Interaktion
Kontakte und Feiern
Und Smalltalk Dinger
Heißt nicht
Zwangsläufig
Dass man ich meine
Ihr wisst das ich das übelste Kellerkind schon immer gewesen bin
Aber es heißt nicht
Zwangsläufig
Dass man wirklich sprichwörtlich den ganzen Tag im Keller sitzen will
Es gibt so eine widersprüchliche Sache
Die ich mir zum Beispiel bei mir auch nicht so richtig erklären kann
Und zwar
Ich habe überhaupt kein Bock auf soziale Interaktion
Und ich kann es mir auch nicht vorstellen wie das ist
Es gibt ja Leute
Die haben irgendwie 30, 40 Freunde
Und die werden dann quasi jeden Tag angerufen
So nach dem Motto
Und Karl kommst du heute noch vorbei
Wir machen diese
Super und ach der Jonny ist auch da
Cool den habe ich schon ein halbes Jahr nicht gesehen
So irgendwie Donnerstag Abend
23 Uhr
Alter was ist mit euch los
Gibt es wirklich Leute die da Bock drauf haben
Gut aber anscheinend gibt es das ja
Sonst
Sonst wären die Bars und alles nicht so voll
Naja zumindest
Auf sowas habe ich überhaupt keinen Bock
Aber
Was mir wiederum gefällt ist
Wenn ich irgendwas präsentieren kann
Oder so das finde ich nice
Also wenn ich mich irgendwie vorne
Hinten stellen kann
Das habe ich früher überhaupt keinen Bock drauf
Also ganz früher noch in der Schule
Aber das mache ich tatsächlich gerne
Ich weiß nicht wie das genau zusammen passt
Aber das liegt vielleicht auch daran
Dass das keine soziale Interaktion
Und Smalltalk
Gelaber ist wie das andere
Sondern relativ
Ja Themen
Themenspezifisch
Und
Es ist ja keine Interaktion
Es ist ja keine Präsentation
Wie auf irgendeiner Feier oder so
Ne
Es geht ja im Prinzip darum
Dass du deine Sache rüberbringst
Die anderen müssen ja dann nicht so
Wisst ihr das ist ja sehr einseitig
Natürlich
Muss man schon gucken
Ob das gut ankommt und sowas
Aber das mache ich tatsächlich gerne
Eventuell weil du Youtube machst
Ne das war vorher auch schon so
Aber Youtube hat auf jeden Fall was gebracht
Dazu
Also Youtube hat auf jeden Fall was dazu gebracht
Das habe ich euch ja auch schon oft erzählt
Also wo Youtube auf jeden Fall was dazu gebracht hat
Ist wenn man
So ein paar Hänger hat
Also wenn der Kopf
Grad irgendwie Aussätze hat
Und du nicht genau weißt wie es weiter geht
Ich habe so ein paar Standardsprüche
Durch Youtube gelernt die ich immer sage
Wenn ich nicht weiter weiß
Und mittlerweile kann ich die so gut auswendig
Oder was heißt auswendig
Mittlerweile kommen die schon so automatisch in den Redefluss mit rein
Dass man eigentlich gar nicht mehr
Merkt dass ich das gar nicht sagen wollte
Und etwas anderes
Weitermachen will
Ja was ich beispielsweise total oft sage ist
Ja und was man auch nicht vergessen darf
Oder
Oder was man auch dazu sagen muss
Das sind so Sachen
Dann wisst ihr immer wenn ihr das hört
Ich muss gerade kurz zwei Sekunden
Überlegen was ich jetzt als nächstes
Sagen will
Das sage ich total oft
Das hat bloß noch keiner mitgekriegt
Das ist mein Äh quasi
Nicht dass ich auch ab und zu mal Äh sagen würde
Aber gibt Leute die sagen laufend Äh
Ja so oft sage ich es jetzt
Gibt Leute die sagen laufend Äh
Und ich habe anstatt Äh
Halt so
Ein paar Übergangssätze
Wo ich kurz nachdenken kann
Das hat sich auf jeden Fall gelohnt durch Youtube
Weil vorher hatte ich das nicht
Und das ist auch eine Übungssache
Aber ansonsten muss ich sagen
Ehrlich ich glaube nicht
Dass Youtube jetzt
Das unbedingt großartig fördert
Weil es ist schon ein Unterschied
Jetzt überlegt euch mal
Ihr steht auf der Arbeit
Vor vor 20 Leuten
Und müsst was präsentieren
Oder ihr sitzt vor eurem Computer
Nehmt zeitversetzt
Was auf
Das gucken sich dann 20.000 30.000
40.000 50.000 Leute an
Bei dem ersten
Kann sich glaube ich jeder reinversetzen
Dass man ein bisschen nervös ist
Allein schon weil es direkt ist
Du stehst da die gucken dich an
Und die erwarten jetzt auch
Dass du was gescheites von dir gibst
Versus Aufnahme wo du weißt
Das ist einfach was komplett anderes
Also das
Ich weiß nicht
Ob es Leute gibt die sagen
Das bringt was aber aus meiner Sicht
Bringt das nichts
Livestream vielleicht schon ein bisschen mehr
Das aber auch nicht wirklich
Weil du präsentierst ja nicht immer
Eines deiner Lieblingsthemen
Ja und
Vor allem ist halt Livestream
Auch nicht so
Nicht so fokussiert in 15 Minuten
Muss jetzt das Thema gut rüber gebracht werden
Sondern es ist guckt euch das hier an
Ich setz einfach sinnlos vor mein Rechen und schwätz
Irgendwas ins Mikrofon
So könntest du keine Präsentation halten
Die Leute würden jetzt schon pennen
Oder denken Alter was erzählt uns der Max da wieder
Eine halbe Stunde für einen Kack
Was ihr euch wahrscheinlich Sonntags morgens denkt
Wenn ich eigentlich sag wir gucken jetzt Videos
Und dann schaffen wir es in 3,5 Stunden
Wie letzten Sonntag
Letzten Sonntag in 3,5 Stunden
Sonst ein Viertelstunden Video anzugucken
Alter
Oder wie lang ging das Stream am Wochenende
Wartet mal
Moment
Fuck liegt
Nein ich hab die doch schon längst wieder abgeschaltet
Die bringt keine Bestätigungs E-Mail hinzuschicken
Aufwachen Stream
3 Stunden 14 Leute
Wir haben ein 20 Minuten 15 oder 20 Minuten
Video geguckt in der ganzen Zeit
Und eigentlich ist das ein Stream
So ein paar aktuelle Sachen anzugucken
Github und so was und ein paar Youtube Videos zu gucken
Ich hab genau ein Video geschafft
Und ich hab random echt vom 100. ins 1000.
Geschwätzt
So kannst du natürlich keine Präsentation halten
Die pennen dir ein die Leute
Lass dich nie wieder was halten
Aber das mach ich witzigerweise ganz gern
Ich würde das nicht unbedingt
Alles in einen Top schmeißen
Das hört sich ein bisschen falsch an
Das in diese
Aufzählung noch Haustiere
Mit aufgenommen wurden von dir
Jetzt einfach 20 Sekunden Delay
Dann musst du
Wenn du FFZ hast
Oder irgendeins der Twitch Plugins
Alter
Ich benutze den Account nicht
Und die E-Mail Adresse ist längst abgeschaltet
Twitch
Geht mir nicht auf den Keks
Ich bin Omega Keckel
Glaubt ihr ernsthaft ich benutze das für irgendwas
Das ist einfach hier als Streaming Account
Dass ich nicht aus versehen irgendwas leake
Naja
Was wollte ich euch hier zeigen
Keine Ahnung
Ich würde sehr gerne Sidetracken
Und dann vergesse ich wieder die Hälfte
Achso ja hier 20 Sekunden Delay
Wenn du beispielsweise FFZ installiert hast
Da hast du hier so einen Knopf
Reset Player
Das ist das gleiche wie
Seite neu laden
Nur dass du die Seite nicht neu laden musst
Find ich sehr praktisch
Hast du dein Home Assistant
Auf einem Raspberry Pi laufen
Nein hab ich nicht
Ich hab mein Home Assistant auf einem
Server Gen 8 Plus
Oder
Gen 10 Plus
Der letzte den es gibt
Laufen
Ne asozialer Kontakt wie auf dem Hauptbahnhof
Leon danke für den Sub
Was zum Thema
Oh kann ich das aufmachen
How to fit in with the Linux Community
Ah
Das ist ja auch schon Klischee
Ich mein
Das kommt nicht von ungefähr
Ein Anteil solcher Leute
Aber da sind wir ja schon weit weit weg von
Wo ich das hier gelesen hab
Ich habs erst falsch gelesen
Irgendwie musste ich daran denken
Dass ich gebannt bin auf Ebay Kleinanzeigen
Wobei es heißt ja gar nicht mehr Ebay Kleinanzeigen
Es heißt ja nur Kleinanzeigen
Ich weiß nicht warum
Aber ich bin gebannt auf Ebay Kleinanzeigen
Ich hab das nie benutzt aber ich bin gebannt
Moin Michael 5 Spilian
Ja und das find
Da hab ich halt
Oh ne ist schon wieder ausgef.. Alter wo da vorn was hier los?
Wo da vorn?
Mach keinen Scheiß Alter
That's
Ne ist doch überhaupt nix
Gar nix
Der Chat gebanet mich
Ich mein
Zutrauen würd ich denen
Dass das wieder kaputt ist
Wisst ihr
Da hast du schon recht
Das Problem bei mir ist
Ich trink eigentlich nie was
Außer vielleicht schon ein bisschen was an Weihnachten und Silvester
Aber eigentlich trink ich nie was
Wir hatten letztens so ein Teambuilding Workshop
Hab ich euch ja erzählt
Wo das wir im Dezember da was hatten
Und ganz so viel Details kann ich euch natürlich nicht erzählen
Und da gab es auch kostenlos Essen trinken und so
Und ich hab mich so krass voll gefressen Alter
Voll übertrieben ne
Also ihr wisst wie das ist
Leute kostenloses Essen
Es ist
Es gibt so zwei Sachen
All you can eat Buffet
Und kostenloses Essen
Das setzt es psychologisch irgendwie
Ich weiß nicht wie man das
Warum
Ja
Das setzt es bei mir im Kopf aus
Bei all you can eat Buffets muss ich
Mehr fressen als gesundheitlich
Und zu der jetzigen
Lage angebracht ist
Ich hab bei all you can eat Sushi
Schon so viel gefressen
Dass ich quasi gar nicht mehr richtig zum Bahnhof laufen konnte
Weil mir der Bauch weh getan hat
Ich hab sobald es kostenloses Essen gibt
Was ganz gut schmeckt
Und sobald es all you can eat Sushi gibt
Da legt sich so ein Knopf bei mir im Kopf um
Ich muss so viel fressen wie geht
Und das war bei diesem Teambuilding Workshop auch
Da gab es auch so viel zu fressen wie geht
Das Ding war
Es gab auch so viel zu trinken wie geht
Und so die Leute um mich drum herum
Und so alle so
Oh ein Rotwein aus der Provinz
Bla bla bla
Und hier aus Italien
Aber haben wir nicht
Irgend so ein tolles
Sekunde
Irgendwo aus der Provinz
Oh ich kann dieses Emote nie verwenden
Ich muss es jetzt benutzen
Wo ist es denn
Ich find es nicht
Hätte ich das mal ordentlich programmiert
Dann hätte ich jetzt eine Suchfunktion
Wo ist mein Weinteil
Ne das meine ich nicht
Ich hab doch den Pfeifer
Das Weinglas irgendwo
Ja das habe ich gesucht
Das habe ich gebraucht
Ich hab eine Suche
Aber die funktioniert nicht
Meine
Ich sag ja immer bei mir funktioniert immer alles first try
Ich suche jetzt mal nach
Wie heißt das die Mode
Too smart
Ich suche jetzt mal
Und jetzt ist es kaputt
Es geht noch beim ersten
Das ist seit
5 Jahren schon verbuggt
Frontend mäßig
Die Suche funktioniert nicht
Lässt sich bestimmt total easy fixen
Zumindest
Da haben wir
Ja
Ja habe ich damals
Würde ich in der heutigen Zeit auch nicht mal verwenden
Aber
Das habe ich damals reingezogen
Habe ich eigentlich auch nie verwendet
Weil ganz ehrlich das kannst du immer eigentlich
Eigentlich kannst du das immer nur in
Unglücklichen Zusammenhängen verwenden
Und dementsprechend
Verwende ich das Emote nicht
Aber
Um mal zu der eigentlichen Sache
Zurück zu kommen
Selbst dort wo es kostenlos
Zu trinken gab
Gefressen habe ich ohne Ende
Aber
Im Vergleich zu den anderen
Ja irgendwie Whisky sowieso
Oder hier ein
Rotwein aus der Provinz
Von Frankreich
Wisst ihr was ich getrunken habe
Die ganzen 2 Tage
Ich habe eine Cola getrunken
Und das Rest Wasser
Einfach nur Wasser
Also mit kostenlos zu trinken
Kannst du mich echt nicht locken
Ich habe nur Wasser
Und eine Cola getrunken
Dafür habe ich das alles was es zu essen gab
Habe ich in Massen
Reingehauen
Wasser ist Beste
Da muss ich nicht dein Mind Changen
Ja und da habe ich keinen Bock
Dazu wollte ich eigentlich was sagen
Und da habe ich keinen Bock
Dass es erst erträglich ist wenn man sich vorher was reinhauen muss
Deswegen ich sage sowas mittlerweile
Eigentlich ab wenn ich auf solche Sachen
Keinen Bock habe
Wo man Bock hat hin zu gehen
Das ist bei mir halt nicht so viel
Aber ansonsten sage ich da
Mittlerweile ab
Neue Kubernetes Challenge Seite für dich
Ok Moment lass mich mal kurz gucken
Ich muss ja immer
Ups ich bin im falschen Fenster
Sieht gar nicht so schlecht aus
Wo hast du denn das her
Learning Platform to Mauster
To Master Cloud Native Craft
Cool
Ja
Yep Clock
Wir haben da noch mehr solcher Dinger
Ich finde es gut dass die zur Zeit so ein bisschen aus dem Boden sprießen
Ich mache die gerne
Und bringe immer guten Stream Content
Sekretärin war mega pisst
Dass ich zur Weihnachtsfeier Urlaub genommen habe
Meine Sekretärin
Du hast eine eigene Sekretärin
Dann bist du aber wahrscheinlich so hoch
In der Hierarchie Ebene
Dass es wahrscheinlich sogar erwartet wird
Dass du auf der Weihnachtsfeier auftauchst
Vielleicht
Könnte es sein dass du die Weihnachtsfeier
Sogar selbst veranstaltet hast
Also
Wenn es deine Weihnachtsfeier wäre
Und ich wäre deine Sekretärin
Was ja in der heutigen Zeit kein Problem wäre
Dann wäre ich auch pisst
Wenn der Chef nicht selbst
Auf die Weihnachtsfeier kommt
Bestimmt der CEO
Seine Weihnachtsfeier
Danke für den Sub
Wie empfindest du dann fachliche Gespräche
Auf Augenhöhe
Kommt drauf an um was es geht
Also
Es ist jetzt nicht so dass ich wahnsinnig gerne
Irgendwie
Wie nennt man das so
Mitarbeitergespräche machen würde
Ist nicht so dass ich da so wahnsinnig scharf drauf bin
Dass ich das jetzt jeden zweiten Tag bräuchte
Aber ich find's nicht verkehrt
Ich find's sogar ganz gut dass es das gibt
Ich mach das so
Ich hab zwar keinen Bock auf diese Gespräche
Weil meistens ist das
Zumindest in der alten Firma war das so
Mal gucken wie das jetzt in der neuen ist
Ja im Prinzip ist das für eine Stunde
Angesetzt
In zwei Minuten bist du eigentlich zum größten Teil durch
Und dann laberst du halt random Zeug
Naja
Zumindest ich mach das immer so
Weil wenn ich eine Sache damals in der Schule
Gelernt hab ist
Das es ein Fehler ist
Wenn man Sachen nicht gerne macht
Und das hab ich aus
Einer Erfahrung gespürt
Wenn man Sachen nicht gerne macht
Sie möglichst lange zu verdrängen
Und dann
Möglichst unvorbereitet rein zu gehen
Weil dann erfüllt sich das
Wieder von selbst
Also mal angenommen
Nehmen wir mal ein konkretes Beispiel
Mal angenommen
Lehrer sagt ey wir haben jetzt diese fünf Themen zur Auswahl
Jeder muss was präsentieren
Sucht euch ein Thema aus
Und ihr habt da überhaupt keinen Bock drauf
Ihr sucht euch ein Thema auf
Ihr sucht euch ein Thema aus
Und dann
Wisst ihr genau am 25. bin ich dran
Und ihr macht einfach gar nichts
Weil ihr wisst
Ihr hasst es Sachen zu präsentieren
Ihr habt da keinen Bock drauf
Und ihr verdrängt das einfach
Und einer der Gründe warum ihr das nicht mögt
Ist weil es halt
Ja weil ihr auf das Thema keinen Bock habt
Und weil euch das Präsentieren abfuckt
Und es immer scheiße läuft
Wir können davon ausgehen
Wenn ihr da quasi nichts macht
Bis zum Tag wo es ist
Oder vielleicht bis zum Tag vorher
Da könnt ihr davon ausgehen
Dass das quasi eine Art selbsterfüllende Prophezeiung ist
Ihr habt keinen Bock drauf
Ist weil es immer scheiße läuft
Aber dann könnt ihr sicher sein
Dass es scheiße läuft
Ihr sorgt quasi selbst dafür
Also mit dafür dass es scheiße läuft
So und deswegen ist eine Sache
Die habe ich tatsächlich in der Schule
Damals habe ich beispielsweise total ungern
Irgendwelche Präsentationen gemacht
Gelernt habe ist selbst wenn man keinen Bock drauf hat
Auf irgendwelche Gespräche
Es ist immer sinnvoll sich drauf vorzubereiten
Weil sobald ihr euch drauf vorbereitet
Habt ihr einen riesen Vorteil
Weil meistens haben sich die anderen
Gar nicht so großartig drauf vorbereitet
Ihr müsst euch mal überlegen
Euer Chef
Muss 20 dieser Gespräche führen
Wie gut wird er sich
Auf das einzelne Gespräch vorbereitet haben
Ja
Hat sich ein paar Sachen zu euch aufgeschrieben
Und sonst wie und das wars
Also wirklich viel Material wird er nicht haben
Habt ihr euch jetzt aber mal
Also sagt man mal so
Euer Chef macht sich vielleicht pro Mitarbeiter
Fünf Minuten Gedanken was er in so einem Gespräch
tun kann wenn es wieder darum geht und gut ist
Das heißt ihr könnt
Wenn ihr euch einfach mal eine halbe Stunde hinsetzt
Und euch was überlegt und auch Sachen aufschreibt
Richtig punkten in solchen Gesprächen
Weil ihr einfach
Euch im Vorfeld schon ein bisschen Gedanken gemacht habt
Und wenn ihr im Hinterkopf habt
Dass ihr vielleicht die ein oder andere Sache
Durchsetzen wollt, umsetzen wollt, ändern wollt
Was auch immer und ihr euch da was gutes für überlegt
Und am besten auch
Den Fehler habe ich früher
Auch gemacht zumindest denke ich
Dass es ein Fehler ist
Man blendet ja gerne
Unangenehme Sachen aus
Und kennt ihr den Gedankengang
Dass ihr euch
Überlegt okay da und da
Habe ich wieder ein unangenehmes Gespräch
Und
Ich würde aber gerne mal
Punkt XY ansprechen
Aber in dem Moment wo ihr euch denkt
Ich würde mal gerne Punkt XY ansprechen
Hört ihr im Hinterkopf schon quasi
Was die anderen dazu
Sagen werden und ihr wisst das euch die Antworten
Abfacken und deswegen sagt ihr Punkt XY
Oder erst gar nicht
Hat man verstanden was ich meine
Also ihr hört im Kopf quasi schon
Nennen wir es mal
Die Gegenargumente gegen das was ihr eigentlich
Sagen wollt und dadurch
Dass ihr schon quasi gleich im Kopf damit rechnet
Oh da gibt es wieder negativen Gegenwind
Ah dann habe ich da gar keinen Bock drauf
Und mach das nicht
Genau an der Stelle ist eigentlich das Problem
Es ist sogar ganz gut wenn man selbst schon
Drauf kommt was könnte denn
Jemand dagegen anbringen
Gegen das was ihr sagt
Und euch schon im Vorfeld überlegen
Okay ich weiß genau der Typ
Oder der Typ der kommt immer mit dem
Gleichen Spruch auf sowas
Und dann überlegt ihr euch schon im Vorfeld
Irgendeine schlüssige
Antwort da drauf oder sei es
Wenn ihr einen Kollegen habt der immer irgendwelche
Zusammenhanglosen Dinge erzählen müsst
Dass ihr eine gute Antwort da drauf habt
Weil spontan es gibt Leute die können sowas spontan
Spontan fällt euch meistens da nicht so
Immer das beste ein
Das heißt ein bisschen Vorbereitung ist wirklich
Gar nicht verkehrt
Und das mache ich mittlerweile auch bei allen Sachen
Sei es unser Teambuilding Workshop
Da war ich der einzige
Hat der Trainer gemeint
Ich war der einzige der jemals eine Themenliste
Zum Teambuilding Workshop mitgebracht hat
Und ich habe ihm halt nur gemeint
Ja gut das ist weil ich mir hoffe
Dass ich vielleicht auch was tut
Ich meine was ich nicht sagen wollte ist
Bevor wir hier einfach nur die ganze Zeit
Irgendwelche blöden Spielchen machen
Können wir ja auch was richtiges machen
Aber deswegen hatte ich eine Liste dabei
Wo wir einen Punkt davon ansprechen können
Und deswegen finde ich es sinnvoll
Sich im Vorfeld
Gedanken zuzumachen
Und seit ich das mache
Finde ich solche Gespräche
Auch wenn sie immer gewisse
Ja gewisse Drucksituation sind
Wenn du da sitzt
Dein Chef sitzt dir gegenüber
Und er sagt ja was können wir denn da reinschreiben
Und was denkt der davon
Es ist Blödsinn
Im Vorfeld den Kopf in den Sand zu stecken
Und zu warten bis das Gespräch ist
Am besten ist sich wirklich Gedanken drüber machen
Ok was sind dann meine Punkte
Was könnte der andere da drauf sagen
Und sich dann schon so ein bisschen überlegen
Ok wie könnte man in so einem Gespräch vorgehen
Und ihr werdet feststellen
Ihr seid deutlich entspannter
Und
Es entsteht auch ein viel
Ein viel besserer Fluss
Und am Ende kommt auch was besseres raus
Ne also
Wie gesagt ich habe keinen Bock
Ich müsste auch nicht jeden zweiten Tag
Mit meinem Chef irgendwelche
Abstimmungsgespräche
Vorstellungsdinger
Erklärtermine oder sonst was haben
Aber wenn es die gibt
Finde ich die gut
Ich habe sogar bei unserem Teambuilding angesprochen
Dass ich mir wünschen würde
Dass mein Chef öfters greifbar wäre
Versus das was er
Wie es jetzt gerade aktuell ist
Ich weiß der kann da auch nichts für
Der hat auch keinen Bock den ganzen Tag zu mieten
Aber bei dem ist das so
Und ich finde so Sachen mittlerweile ganz gut
Wobei das wahrscheinlich gar nicht das ist was du meinst
Oder
Nachdem ich jetzt 20 Minuten geredet habe
Ich glaube das ist gar nicht was du meinst
Du meinst
Wenn du
Im Team oder in irgendeinem Projekt miteinander
Miteinander schwätzt
Über irgendwelche Technik Sachen
Ja nö das ist doch ganz normal
Das ist doch gut
Da spricht ja nichts dagegen
Das stört mich nicht
Das sind auch so Dinger
Wo man über Gott und die Welt geredet wird
Wo ich dann erzählt kriege
Wie es der Oma geht
Oder
Wie komisch die Leute im Urlaub drauf waren
Und sowas
Das interessiert mich halt so überhaupt gar nicht
Wenn es darum geht
So nach dem Motto
Warum C++ die beste Programmiersprache ist
Da bin ich sofort
Für fachliche Gespräche am Start
Einfach nur
Ich habe den Namen vom Hardware Rad
Hardware Rad Profi Hard
Ja die Sprüche
Das ist tatsächlich ein Wort
Das kann ich mir 1 zu 1
In der Stimmlage von Hardware Rad vorstellen
Bei Hardware
Ich kann das nicht
Hardware Rad
Ne
Bei Hardware
Hardware sagt er immer
Bei Hardware Rad
Macht der überhaupt noch Videos
Schon ewig nichts gesehen
Aber sein Shop läuft gut
Was
Packweight
Hast du da die Docker Version
Was
Ich bin verwirrt
Entweder war das eine Antwort auf was
Was ich vor 3 Stunden gesagt habe
Ach Home Assistant
Nee Home Assistant habe ich
In der VM laufen
Das Home Assistant OS
Home Assistant OS
Als Image
In KVM
Ja du ja aus Frankfurt kommst
Wollte ich mal fragen ob die Fiber One
Als ESP legit ist
Ich habe mit dem noch nie was zu tun
Moment
Ist Fiber One nicht dieser komische
Moment Moment
Fiber One war das nicht dieser komische
Kram den wir letztens
Die mit kostenlos
Ne das ist was anderes
Wie hieß denn diese Chat
Erinnert ihr euch noch dran
Wir hatten doch letzten so was mal
Kostenloses Gigabit
Das waren andere oder
Gigafiber war das
Was ist denn eigentlich aus denen geworden
Wo alle gesagt haben
Das klingt ja sehr shady Gigafiber
Oh
1.0 Rezession
Da kam jetzt nichts mehr oder
Das war irgendwann
Also
War nicht eine Klage oder
Weiß ich nicht
Hab ich nichts mehr mitbekommen
Zumindest
Zumindest ist das halt auch was
Wo ich nie im Leben was abschließen würde
Bei My Deals
Genau das My Deals Video haben wir gesehen
Und
Vieles der Sachen die die dort erzählt haben
Kann man sich
Kann man sich mal ein bisschen drüber nachdenken
Auch selbst denken
Aber gut das das mal gesagt haben
Das das alles
Sehr shady wirkt
Also aber
Fiber One kenne ich nicht
Hab ich noch nie was mit zu tun gehabt
Mit Fiber One
Aber die haben doch ganz gute Bewertungen
Keine Ahnung
Der Rübel danke für den Sub
Abmahnung vom Verbraucherschutz
Ach wirklich
Wirklich
Kopie Link Address
Kostenlose Glasfaser
Verbraucherschützer mahnen Gigafiber ab
Das ist das einzige was die monieren
Na gut
Aber mal gucken was da rauskommt
Da bin ich mal gespannt ob wir für den wieder was hören
Fiber One habe ich noch nicht
Weder Kontakt mit gehabt noch
Selbst verwendet noch kenne ich jemand
Der die verwendet
Am Montag fange ich meine erste Festanscheinung
Nach dem Schuljahren Softwareentwickler
Hast du zufällig ein paar Tipps
Boah
Die nur nach 15 Sachen die ich immer erzähle
Aber ok
Naja
Also ich kenne dich nicht
Deswegen weiß ich nicht ob du das machen würdest
Eine Sache die mich zumindest bei
Neuen Azubis genervt hat früher
Immer ist
Wenn die am ersten Tag gleich so wichtig getan haben
Ich weiß du bist kein Azubi aber ich sage
Könnte ja da auch sein
Wenn die am ersten Tag so wichtig getan haben
So nach dem Motto
Ach eigentlich weiß ich das schon ich mach das eh nur damit ich dann
IHK Zettel hab
Das waren meistens die die am wenigsten Plan hatten
Vielleicht am Anfang nicht zu sehr auf dicke Hose machen
Ansonsten generell so die üblichen Sachen
Die ich immer sage
Jedes Unternehmen tickt ein bisschen anders
Die haben alle eigene Abkürzungen
Eigene Bezeichnungen
Gibt es bei vielen Unternehmen die gleichen
Strukturen
Die gleichen Abläufe Prozesse
Vorgehen
Die Dinger nennen sie bloß immer anders
Ja und viele Unternehmen
Haben einen Hang dazu Sachen abzukürzen
Das heißt
Das beste was du machen kannst ist
Erstmal versuchen ein bisschen durch zu blicken
So durch das
So durch das dickicht aus neuen Sachen
Ja und
Du musst auch nicht versuchen
Gleich am ersten Tag richtig
Die Daten mit allem
Es wird eh nicht klappen
Je nachdem bei welchem Unternehmen du anfängst
Hast du noch nicht mal einen funktionierenden Laptop am ersten Tag
Hab ich schon Dinger gesehen teilweise
Wo es ne Woche
Also dort beim letzten Laden wo ich gewesen bin
Da hatten wir mal einen
Das war jetzt aber selbst verschuldet
Selbst verschuldet von dem
Da hatten wir mal einen der war über nen Monat da
Der sollte sich damals
Ich glaube der sollte sich damals um Zabbix Monitoring kümmern
Wenn ich das richtig richtig in Erinnerung hab
Sollte der damals machen
Und nach nem Monat oder so
Auf irgendeiner Teamrunde
Hatte ihn mein Chef damals gefragt
So ja und wie siehts eigentlich mit Zabbix aus
Und da hat er ernsthaft gesagt
Er muss erst noch sein Notebook einrichten
Seit nem Monat
Also naja
Gut der hat danach dann aber auch nix mit Zabbix
Mehr großartig gemacht
Der hat quasi der war dann nen Monat da
Hat sein Notebook eingerichtet und dann war er irgendwann wieder weg
Ja versuch erstmal ein bisschen durch zu blicken
Was da wie wo läuft
Jede Firma hat
Tickt da ein bisschen anders
Viele Sachen sind gleich
Werden bloß anders genannt
Dass du erstmal versuchst rauszukriegen
Wie heißen hier spezielle Dinger
Wo muss man hin
Bei welchen Problemen
Also wo wendet man sich hin
Wenn das Notebook nicht funktioniert
Wo wendet man sich hin
Wenn die Rufumleitung nicht funktioniert
Welche Abkürzungen
Hat das Zeug alles
Und vor allem
Eine Sache ganz wichtig
Eine Sache finde ich tatsächlich
Nicht unwichtig
Da habe ich auch schon negative Erfahrungen gemacht
Weil es gibt Leute
Die tun ganz gerne so
Als wären sie der Macker
Und der der das sagen hat
Sind es aber gar nicht
Wenn du es nicht weißt
Direkt wer dir was zu sagen hat
Frag deinen Chef
Den du ja hoffentlich am ersten Tag
Der dich am ersten Tag abholt oder sowas
Direkt so nach dem Motto
Alter hier wie sieht es aus
Aber das ist nicht schlecht zu wissen
Wer hat dir was zu sagen
Also wer kann dir nicht
Wer kann dir Aufträge geben
Und wer kann dir was sagen
Dass du was machen musst
Aufträge geben ist ja relativ normal
Dass es von allen kommt
Aber die nach dem Motto
Das musst du jetzt machen
Vor dem anderen wer darf das
Und wenn dein Chef sagt
Wenn ich ein Ticket tragen kann bin ich
Dann weißt du schon gleich ey
Wenn irgendjemand um die Ecke kommt
Und sagt das Ticket ist jetzt Priorität Nummer 1
Du denkst aber nicht
Dass das Priorität Nummer 1 ist
Dann kannst du gleich sagen
Wenn du denkst dass das Priorität 1 ist
Geht zu meinem Chef
Also zu wissen wer einem was zu sagen hat
Ist echt nicht unwichtig
Das heißt nicht
Dass man sich super am ersten Tag
Versteht mich jetzt nicht falsch
Dass man sich am ersten Tag hier auf
Super unkooperativ machen soll
So nach dem Motto ich mach nix
Bevor du zu meinem Chef gehst
So ist das nicht gemeint oder
Ich hoffe das hat man nicht so verstanden
Ich meine nur dass man erstmal
So prinzipiell klärt wer ist
Also nicht nur wer dein Chef ist
Sondern wer dir Aufträge
Kann auch sein dass du in irgendeinem Projekt bist
Wo du dann Projektleiter hast
So einfach abcheckst okay
Wer kann dir Anweisungen geben
Die du dann befolgen
Musst selbst wenn du nicht willst
Man Aufträge geben kann dir viel
Aber wenn du dann sagst
Nö finde ich nicht wichtig ist okay
Aber wenn dein Chef sagt hier mach mal
Dann kann er halt auch
Ist er an der Stelle wo er es sagen darf
Hat man verstanden was ich meine
Wie gesagt ich meine nicht
Dass man sich am Anfang gleich
Querstellen sollte
Versuchen mal
Einen guten Eindruck zu machen
Am Anfang ist nie verkehrt erster Eindruck zählt oftmals
Selbst mit Eis danke für den Sub
Ach ja pro Gruppe eine Sekretär
Ach so okay
Hab schon gedacht das war deine Weihnachtsfeier
Max kann mich seit heute Nachmittag
Nicht mehr auf meine Remote Linux Kiste
Per SSH einloggen schlecht
Sadge
Immer Access denied
Trotz korrektem User und Passwort
Kann das Linux
Naja die Passwörter laufen ab
Je nachdem was du gesetzt hast
Wobei das eigentlich normalerweise nicht der Fall ist
Aber du kannst das machen
Gerade für normale User
Kannst das machen das die Passwörter ablaufen
Oder
Logst du dich per Key ein
Ne mit korrektem User und Passwort kann das
Einlehnungsproblem sein
Achso Moment das ist ein Public Server
Also
Wenn das ein Public Server ist dann ist das
Theoretisch möglich
Da würde ich mir erstmal Gedanken drüber machen
Wie einfach war mein Passwort zu erraten
Und wenn es
Ein Remote Server ist
Dann ist das kein Problem da kannst du nämlich über dein
Admin Konsole
Wo auch immer du bist bei welchem Hosting Anbieter
Kannst du per Admin Konsole auf dein
Linux Server drauf
Und du kannst den Linux Server
Rebooten über die Admin Konsole
Und dann per
Bootmenü
Starten das geht
Je nach Betriebssystem geht es ein bisschen anders
Bei manchen musst du gleich
Init gleich bin Bash reinschreiben
Bei manchen musst du 1 reinschreiben
Bei manchen musst du S reinschreiben
Und dann kannst du über die Admin
Konsole
Kannst du Rebooten
Mit einer Root Shell und auf
Das System zugreifen
Ansonsten kannst du das Ding sicherlich immer noch mit
Image starten mit irgendeinem Iso Image
Aber wenn du Remote PSSH
Nicht mehr dran kommst ist die Admin Konsole
Bei deinem Hosting Anbieter wahrscheinlich das einzige
Was du machen kannst
Ja das stört mich nicht
Wenn es um konkrete Sachen geht
Ich guck mal Leute
um so random Zeug geht, was mich
interessiert, dann habe ich so Probleme oder dann
nerven mich so soziale Interaktionen.
Ich kann beispielsweise ohne Probleme
5 Stunden am Stück, 7, 8 Stunden
am Stück mit Leuten im Discord hocken,
wenn wir MMO Kreiselcrime machen.
PvP oder
irgendwelches PvE Zeug oder so,
überhaupt kein Problem. Und da sind
die übelsten random Leute dabei.
Es sind Deutsche dabei,
es sind Franzosen dabei, es sind Engländer,
es sind Niederländer dabei, alle möglichen
Leute sind dabei.
Und alle stammeln sich da auf Englisch ein bisschen
was bei zurecht. Wobei man ehrlich sagen muss,
umso öfters man
das übt und man sich
so in der jeweiligen
Fachsprache
bewegt, dann geht das ganz gut.
Also Englisch
auf IT-Ebene funktioniert mittlerweile ganz gut
und Englisch im Gaming-Sektor funktioniert
mittlerweile auch ganz gut. Funktioniert
zumindest gut genug, dass ich auf der
Gamescom auf Englisch durchgekommen bin.
Funktioniert auch gut genug, dass ich auf der
Arbeit mit Leuten aus Spanien
oder, wo kam der Typ von der
Telekom her, aus
Bulgarien oder so,
das funktioniert.
Wo ich Probleme habe,
wenn es um englische Sachen geht,
sind dann irgendwelche
also einmal irgendwelche
Dialekte, da steige ich komplett
aus. Wenn die
dann irgendwelche Dialekten schwätzen,
habe ich das Gefühl, die verstehen sich selbst nicht.
Ist aber auch ein bisschen, mit deutschen
Dialekten auch nicht viel anders, aber da
verstehst du gar nichts.
Und ja, wenn es dann halt
so spezifische Sachen sind,
also ich meine, ich könnte
wahrscheinlich durchaus in England einkaufen gehen
und da was finden, aber mich über
irgendwelche aktuellen Ereignisse
des jeweiligen
Zeitgeschehens da unterhalten,
da vielleicht auch ein bisschen,
aber da wird es dann schon schwierig.
Da wird es schwierig. Und eins habe ich
gemerkt, es macht enorm viel
aus, ob man
im Fluss ist oder nicht, was das
angeht. Also wenn ich beispielsweise
jetzt ein paar Tage am Stück
mit den Leuten, die wir aus Spanien
auf der Arbeit haben, rede,
im Teams, auf Englisch, den ganzen Tag,
dann geht das so.
Da fängt man dann auch irgendwann an, so ein bisschen
Themen abseits
ein bisschen zu beschwätzen.
Zum Beispiel
wollte ich den einen Spanier schon die ganze Zeit
mal fragen, ob er eigentlich El Risitas kennt.
Ich weiß, übelste
Random-Frage, aber ich wollte einfach mal
checken, wie bekannt ist der Typ eigentlich in Spanien?
You know El Risitas?
Risitas?
Muss ich ihn mal fragen. Dann geht das
eigentlich ganz gut. Aber wenn man
dann ein paar Tage wieder raus ist, dann ist
er erstmal holprig.
Eigentlich schon für den Sub.
Hast du immer noch nicht gefragt? Ne.
Kostenlos zu haben, wenn man da drauf steht.
Wir haben AKW,
nicht AKW, AKV als Abkürzung.
Okay.
Wir hatten mal,
wie hieß das nochmal?
ADS hatten wir mal.
ADS als Abkürzung.
Leute,
wenn ihr ADS hört,
oder AD, aber ADS hieß es eigentlich,
was heißt das für euch? Was versteht ihr
unter ADS? Also
bezeichnen wir mal zumindest die
die meiste.
Also ADS, manche würden da Ads drunter
verstehen, also Werbung. Mancher
versteht Aim Downside.
ADS
Datenbank von SAP gibt
es auch.
Also die meisten Leute
würden, die ich kenne, verstehen
Active Datenbank. Genau, Totem. Gut,
dass es einer sagt. Die meisten Leute,
die ich kenne, die verstehen darunter wahrscheinlich
Active Directory Services.
Aber nicht so bei uns,
im alten Laden, wo ich gearbeitet habe,
da war das der Antrags-Dispatcher-Service.
Hieß das.
Und nachdem
ADS schon 500 verschiedene Bedeutungen hat,
hat das auch die Leute immer extrem verwirrt,
wenn da einer so
überzeugt von
jeder weiß es doch immer erzählt hat,
ja, okay, da haben wir eine Fehlermeldung im ADS
bekommen und die Leute, die halt neu waren,
die haben sich halt gedacht, ja,
ADS könnte auch Außendienst, bla bla bla
irgendwas heißen.
Und die Leute, die da nicht so oft
dabei waren, die haben da rausgehört, okay,
sie haben wieder eine Fehlermeldung im
Active Directory Service
gehabt. Und das Fatale
bei solchen doppelten
Abkürzungen ist,
wenn du denkst, das macht Sinn,
dann glaubst du auch, dass es so ist.
Also wenn du keine Ahnung von hast,
dass das der Antrags-Dispatcher-Service
ist und du hörst Fehler im
ADS, dann, du denkst dir dann, aha,
Fehler im Active Directory, hab ich verstanden,
abgehakt. Du hast dir immer im Hinterkopf,
ey, die haben doch grad Fehler im Active Directory.
Dabei meinte der was ganz
was anderes. Ja, mir gefällt
mein Notebook, was ich von der aktuellen Arbeit halt auch
nehme. Wobei, das Notebook ist nice,
gegen das Notebook sag ich gar nicht, die Windows-Installation
geht mir auf den Sack.
Das ist, ohne Mist, der
einzige im Vergleich
zum alten Laden,
im Vergleich zum neuen, dort wo ich
jetzt arbeite, der einzig
positive Punkt, vom alten
Arbeitgeber versus
dem neuen.
Dort konnte ich Linux
auf mein Notebook installieren.
Beim neuen kann ich das nicht.
Beim neuen hab ich so ne komische Linux-VM,
glücklicherweise, auf der ich
auch Meister machen kann, was ich will.
Aber ohne die könnte ich gar nicht
arbeiten. Ich hab nen Windows-Notebook.
Es ist so abfuck, Alter.
Du wisst ja, was das Gute ist, morgen ist Freitag.
Ja.
Vielleicht hat dir mein Geschwätz dir ein bisschen was geholfen.
Das erinnert mich an jemand,
der hatte so nen Standardspruch,
das erinnert mich
an jemand aus der
alten Arbeit, und zwar,
wenn du zu dem gesagt hast,
also,
selbst wenn du nicht, es gibt ja viele Leute,
so muss ich das sagen, es gibt ja viele Leute, die haben Probleme
damit, wenn sie sagen, und oftmals
auch zu Recht, wenn sie sagen,
das ist so und so, und du sagst,
ne, das ist falsch.
Da haben die ein Problem damit.
Versteh ich auch, weil, du willst nicht einfach
vor nen Latz geknallt kriegen, ne, das ist falsch.
Du willst ja vielleicht auch hören,
sag mal, bist dir sicher?
Ich hab letztens, ich hab letztens
gelesen, dass es da jetzt das und das gibt.
So, man muss das, muss das ein bisschen,
bisschen halbwegs sinnvoll verpacken,
und dann geht das auch. Aber wir hatten,
wir hatten auf der Arbeit jemand, auf der alten Arbeit
hatten wir jemand, da lief das immer so.
Der hat gesagt,
so, ich sag jetzt mal
irgendwie so ein random, so ein random
Thema, ähm, der hat gesagt,
Playstation Network
bei der PS3 war besser als
Xbox Live.
So, da hab ich ihm gesagt, naja,
sicherlich unterschiedliche,
sicherlich unterschiedliche Geschmackssache,
aber, also, fiktive,
ähm, Konversation,
ja, aber,
ich seh das nicht so.
Guck mal, du musst beispielsweise fürs PSN
nix bezahlen, aber Xbox Live hat Partys
und so. Also, ich find nicht, dass das,
dass das das Bessere ist.
Xbox Live ist aus meiner Sicht eindeutig
besser, so. Und dann hat der als
Antwort gebracht, das war immer seine Standardantwort.
Nein,
das kann nicht sein, da hab ich andere Informationen.
Das war seine
fucking Standardantwort auf alles. Das kann
nicht sein, da hab ich andere Informationen.
Und wenn er dann
gefragt hat, ja, was hast du denn für Informationen,
hat er gesagt, das hab ich doch gerade gesagt.
Das war immer, das war immer
die gleiche, immer die gleich dumme
Diskussion, Alter. Ja, da hab ich
andere Informationen. Ja, und, welche sind das?
Habe ich doch gerade gesagt.
Ja, und,
das ist das Prinzip, im Prinzip
warst du dann wieder bei der Ausgangssituation,
wo du sagen musstest, ja, aber,
ich hab dir doch gerade gesagt, dass die nicht stimmen.
Ja, da hab ich aber andere Informationen.
Ja, und welche? Habe ich doch gerade gesagt.
Ja, aber die stimmen nicht. Aber da hab ich wieder andere Informationen.
Du bist über Endlosschleife, ja?
Endlosschleife. Konntest du
nicht gewinnen. War vorbei.
Ja, da hab ich an, das war immer
der Standard, immer der Standard im
Spruch, Alter.
Also, wir hatten, muss ich echt sagen, wir hatten auf der
alten Arbeit schon echt nervige Leute,
die dann auch in so Positionen waren,
wo man sich immer gedacht hat, wie kommen die
da hin? Ich kann mich noch an,
ich kann mich noch an unseren Change-Manager
erinnern, der keinen Bock hatte,
Changes zu managen und sowas.
Das war eh das Geilste.
Ja, dann kümmer dich doch drum.
Ja, nee, das musst du machen. Ja, aber du bist
doch der Change-Manager.
Okay,
ich will dich jetzt nicht zu hart flamen,
ich war da lange,
ich fand's da lange Zeit auch gut,
hat sich in den letzten Jahren ein bisschen zum Negativen entwickelt,
um es jetzt nicht gar so positiv
darzustellen. Es gibt bei der neuen Arbeit auch
Leute, wo ich mir so denke, Alter, ihr geht mir teilweise
schon ein bisschen auf den Keks, wenn die sich
umgedreht auch denken, ist ja auch überhaupt
nichts Wildes bei. Aber
bei dem letzten Mal, da hatten wir schon echt so ein paar Spezialisten
in der Richtung.
Im jetzigen Team hab ich jemanden, der muss immer
um alles Mögliche diskutieren,
muss immer gucken, dass man das so ein bisschen
umschifft. Aber,
ey, wo kämen wir da hin,
wenn das wirklich alles immer super
reibungslos und harmonisch
und ohne Probleme abläuft? Das ist
nirgendwo so. Wenn du irgendwo
15 Leute auf einem Haufen hast, oder
ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele wir sind, da ist das
du kannst nicht,
und das muss man sich auch abschminken,
du kannst nicht bei 15 Leuten erwarten,
dass jeder mit jedem super klarkommt.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Wichtig ist, dass die Leute insoweit
halbwegs
kompetent genug sind,
die Sachen auch mal
gut sein zu lassen.
Dass man das nicht übertreibt.
Man weiß, okay, mit dem und dem komme ich nicht so hundertprozentig klar,
da gibt es immer Reibereien und Probleme.
Dass man sich ein bisschen Mühe gibt,
die Sachen zu umschiffen.
Man muss es ja nicht immer drauf anlegen.
Und dann kommt man auch wunderbar miteinander aus.
Es gibt aber Leute, die müssen halt immer aus Prinzip
da
Diskussionen anfangen.
Ich gebe mir Mühe, auch wenn ich nicht so die
krassesten Social Skills habe.
Ich gebe mir Mühe, mit allen soweit gut klarzukommen,
dass das auf fachlicher Ebene und Arbeitsebene gut funktioniert.
Und gibt ein paar, mit denen verstehe ich mich besser,
mit denen schwätze ich dann auch mal im Teams ein
bisschen privates Zeug.
Der Rest muss ja nicht.
Wenn wir arbeiten zusammen, wir fahren nicht zusammen in Urlaub.
Mein Windows ist gerade random abgekackt, das kommt vor.
Aber selten, muss man echt sagen.
In letzter Zeit, also in den letzten Jahren über schon sehr selten.
Browser crasht, konnte danach keine Ahnung ...
Tja, F.
Also insgesamt muss man sagen, wenn man das mal vergleicht mit Windows 98 ME
und dem ganzen Shit von damals,
ist Windows mittlerweile doch schon erstaunlich stabil.
Wann hattet ihr, jetzt mal gefragt Chat,
wann hattet ihr euren letzten Windows Crash?
So richtig Blue Screen und
...
eine der üblichen ...
Achso und Chatge,
Übertaktungsversuche nicht mit reinrechnen.
Das, dass das Ding bei Übertaktung,
sowohl GPU-technisch, Grafikkarten-technisch, RAM,
gerade RAM ist sehr anfällig bei Übertaktungen für,
wir machen mal einen Blue Screen.
Das ist natürlich klar,
wenn du die Sachen außerhalb der Spezifikation betreibst
und dann auch teilweise deutlich außerhalb der Spezifikation,
da musst du dich nicht wundern.
Vor einem Jahr,
Undervolten, genau, ja, sowas meine ich jetzt nicht
Ja, random Bugs
Habe ich unter Windows auch, ich meine, das ist wirklich ein Crash
Ja, random, sinnlose random
Bugs habe ich unter Windows auch
Ich bin mir
Immer noch nicht sicher, ob das ein Bug ist
Dass mein VM, wer hier unten so ein
Komisches Ding anzeigt, das macht er noch, sollte der
Normalerweise eigentlich gar nicht
Ja, ich bin auch kein Windows-Fan, das weißt du
Deswegen machen wir eigentlich fast alles unter
Unter Linux, wenn wir was basteln
Also, sobald wir Technik-Krams
Machen, bin ich immer in der Linux-Kiste unterwegs
Übrigens, Fun-Fact, Moment, Moment
Erzähle ich euch gleich, ich muss ja erstmal den Chat aufholen
Sonst wird das nix
Ja, ja, hast schon recht, du hast recht
Meine Interessen
Sind aber halt nicht sonderlich breit gefächert
Ich interessiere mich für ein paar Sachen und dafür dann halt richtig
Und wenn ich mit was anfange
Was mich interessiert, dann interessiert mich das auch
Immer richtig, aber du hast insofern recht
Letztens erst
In der, in
Zwischen zwei Meetings
Mit einem, ne Viertelstunde
Geschwätzt auf der Arbeit
Wir sind im gleichen Raum sitzen geblieben
Eine Meeting war fertig, nächste, nächste Meeting war im gleichen Raum
Mit einem geschwätzt
Ne Viertelstunde, mit dem ich quasi noch nie
Großartig längere Zeit
Geredet hab und worüber haben wir uns
Unterhalten
Über Rennen und Fahrradfahren
Konnte ich früher nicht mitreden
Mittlerweile zumindest
Rudimentär
Hat er dann auch erzählt
So seine Zeit, dann hab ich dann die
Die Garmin App rausgeholt
Hab dir meine Zeiten gezeigt
Dann hat er sein Handy rausgeholt
Benutzt Strava, was sonst
Ganz coolen Leute sind auf Strava
Also
Es kann durchaus helfen
Ein paar allgemeine
Allgemeingültige Sachen im Hinterkopf
Zu haben, wenn man Smalltalk betreiben muss
Aber das Ding ist halt
Ich hab da einfach keinen Bock drauf, das nervt mich
Diese 0815 Smalltalk Sachen
Wenn es um Sachen geht, die mich nicht jucken
Oh
Also zum Beispiel
Bestes Beispiel ist
So und
Frohes neues Jahr und wie war
Wie war Silvester bei dir, was hast du gemacht
Erzähl mal und wie lief's da
Ich will, ich hab keinen
Box zu erzählen
Ich will's auch nicht wissen
Das stresst mich immer
Hä, du hast dir doch gerade selbst
Geantwortet
Du bekommst für die Arbeit
Einen Notebook, hast keinen Desktoprechner, korrekt
Also ein ziemlich fettes Notebook
Also
Von Hardware Ausstattung
Es hat 32 GB RAM
Was ist denn so eine aktuelle
Ich weiß gar nicht wie viele Cores, ehrlich gesagt
Wahrscheinlich 16 mit Hyperthreading
Also inklusive Hyperthreading
Wahrscheinlich 8 und 16 mit Hyperthreading
Das ist gar nicht schlecht
Das Notebook
Leider total verhunzt, was die Windows Installation angeht
Nein
Nein, nein, nein
Bei uns ist hier Versicherung, Compliance und Überprüfung
Und nee, nee, nee, da kann nicht jeder was
Ich kann auf meiner VM glücklicherweise installieren, was ich will
Das sind keine T14, das sind keine IBM
Beziehungsweise Lenovo, nicht IBM
Tja, da habe ich keine Erfahrung mit
Ich kenne nur die Updates unter
Mac OS, äh nicht Mac OS
iOS
Und die dauern teilweise richtig lang
Gerade auf älteren iPads
Ist es teilweise 10, 15 Minuten am updaten
Ich habe übrigens gelesen
Dieses Jahr
Sie sollen die Storage Preise richtig anziehen
Und wisst ihr
Was das erste ist, was passieren wird
Wenn die Storage Preise anziehen
Da kommt Apple um die Ecke und sagt
Ja Moment, also so 32 Gigabyte mehr Flash Speicher in so einem iPhone
Ja das muss schon mal 400 Euro Aufpreis kosten
Oder mit irgendwie sowas kommen die da um die Ecke
Die Flash Aufpreise für Smartphones sind eh jenseits von gut und böse
Die sind durch nichts gerechtfertigt eigentlich
Zumal selbst die kleinste Ausstattung, zumindest mir
Komplett ausreicht, ja
Ich wollte euch irgendwas erzählen
Ach ja, Fun Fact
Was passiert wenn auf Meetings
Über Security Probleme diskutiert wird
Zweiter Tag wo ich da war
War ein
Projektstatus Meeting
Und
Da waren nicht viele da
Dachte ich
Kamen dann aber doch relativ viele rein
Anscheinend waren die alle wieder da
So waren wir dann am Ende doch 10 Leute
Normalerweise sind es noch ein bisschen mehr
Aber waren immerhin
Erste Woche des Jahres war schon
Relativ viel da
Kam rein
So
Und da kam einer von unseren Security Leuten
Und meint hier guckt mal
Ich zeige euch mal was
Das ist ja sein Job
Sowas zu machen
Ich zeige euch mal was
Und da hat er so ein Dashboard gezeigt
Von einem Image Scanner
Es war also man wusste nicht dass es ein Image Scanner war
Ich wusste das es ein Image Scanner ist
Ihr kennt das vielleicht
Es gibt Tools die können Container Images scannen
Und je nachdem was die finden
In diesen Container Images können die sagen
Ob das was im Container Image drinnen gefunden wurde
In der Version aktuell Sicherheitslücken aufweist
Kennt ihr sowas
Wisst ihr was ich meine
Das kenne ich jetzt zum Beispiel nicht
Ja ja genau genau sowas
Genau sowas meine ich
Ja korrekt Trivi
Sowas in der Richtung meine ich
Da kannst du deine Container Images
Mit scannen lassen
Oder kriegst du
Kriegst dann so eine Liste raus
Was da was da
Was da drinnen gefunden wurde
Genau sowas hier in der Richtung
So und
Der hatte
Das kenne ich das kenne ich
Sowas hier meine ich
Und er hatte so eine Liste mit
Der hat unsere Container Images
Also die für das Projekt dort
Vorhanden sind die Images gescannt
Und hatte da eine Liste
Mit 145 Security Problemen
So und von diesen Problemen hatten
Keine Ahnung 30
Oder so
Waren als Critical gekennzeichnet
Da hat er das einfach mal so
Unkommentiert in den Raum gestellt
Und die Leute dann erstmal so
Was ist hier los
Und schon hast du schon die ersten
Leute gesehen so nach dem Motto
Die Hacker klopfen schon an die Tür
So nach dem Motto Datenbankdump
Ist schon im Darknet hochgeladen
So haben die sich schon gedacht
In ihrem Kopf
Übelst Panik
Muss halt dazu sagen
Die meisten Leute die da hocken
Die haben halt nicht wirklich Ahnung gehabt
Was sie da sehen
Und ich hab sie dann versucht zu beruhigen
Das hat nicht so ganz
Nicht so ganz funktioniert
Ja es hat nicht so ganz funktioniert
Ich hab gesagt hier Leute
Also
Genießt das mal mit einer Portion Skepsis
Das ist ein Image Scanner
Der scannt das komplette Container Image
Und guckt nach das heißt noch lange nicht
Dass das was er da drinnen findet
Überhaupt irgendwo verwendet wird
Noch dass das von außen
Irgendwie ausnutzbar wäre
Ja
Zumal das eine Ding hat ein Webfrontend
Das ist eh nur intern erreichbar
Also selbst wenn die es verwenden
Die Chance das es jemand ausnutzen könnte
Sind wirklich äußerst gering
Also mal keine Panik
Am Freitag hab ich einen Termin
Mit dem Security Mensch von uns
Da gucken wir uns das an
Und wir wissen dass es Images sind
Die wir von externen Anbietern kriegen
Also wir können die Images ja auch selbst gar nicht fixen
Ohne riesen Aufwand
Also macht euch mal nicht so viele Gedanken
Es hat nichts gebracht
Ich hab es ein paar mal versucht
Aber nach diesem Intro
Haben die alle Panik geschoben
Und der eine meinte schon sowas wie
Wir müssen aufpassen
Wir müssen aufpassen dass das nicht im nächsten Management Meeting
Im nächsten Management Meeting zur Sprache kommt
Weil wenn die da sehen
Hat 45 hohe Security Probleme
Dann schalten sie uns alles ab
Hahaha
Wir haben übrigens Panik geschoben
Haha
Naja
Ja haben wir
Wir haben aber wahrscheinlich so ziemlich das weird
Ich sag den Namen nicht weil ich mir nicht sicher bin
Ob wir nicht die einzigen sind die das gekauft haben
Wir haben so ziemlich das weirdste und exotischste System
Ever gekauft
Wahrscheinlich weil die eine gute Sales Abteilung haben
Und nicht sonst nix
Ja und eines der
Der
Sachen in diesem Report war
Da stand drinnen
Es wurde Pearl gefunden
Und in der Pearl Version
Gibt es eine kritische Sicherheitslücke
Mit CVE Score
Keine Ahnung
9.3
Oder sowas
Oh Pearl und Pearl darf doch hier gar nicht verwendet werden
Ist doch so alt
Leute das ist
Die haben in ihrem Container Image
Irgendwann halt
Pearl installiert
Das wird für nix verwendet
Es ist einfach nur da
Keine Panik
Das Image ist nicht gut gebaut
Okay ja das versteh ich
Aber ne
Pearl lädt nicht unsere Datenbank ins Darknet hoch
Da hat irgendeiner beim Image bauen
Kein gescheites Base Image verwendet
Oder eben
Standard volles Debian Image
Oder sonst was
Das bisschen das Problem
Das haben sie bei uns auch
Weil irgendjemand mal entschieden hat
Das muss bewertet werden
Ich finde es prinzipiell nicht verkehrt
Das zu bewerten
Aber das muss bei offensichtlichen Sachen schnell abgefackelt werden können
Wenn du sagst
Okay
Pearl Pearl Pearl
Davon 30 Fehler
Wir wissen genau Pearl ist da einfach nur installiert
Der Hersteller sagt selbst wird für nix verwendet
Abgehakt 30 Stück
Zack
Wenn du jeden Furz
Einzel bewerten musst
Obwohl es 30x Pearl ist
Dann machst du nix anderes mehr
Das ist auch wieder so ein Ding
Wo ich mir gedacht habe
Manchmal ist es gar nicht so gut
Im großen
In der großen Runde
Sowas
Als
Dashboard dahin zu klatschen
Da schieben sie wieder Panik
Ich wette mit euch
Termin mit unserem Security Experte
Dazu
Oder Security Team
Da habe ich Termin mit dem zu
Und ich wette
Alle Images
Sind Drittanbieter Images
Und alle Fehler in diesen Images
Sind wahrscheinlich einfach nur schlecht gebaute Images
Und
Alle vielleicht nicht
95%
Ein paar Sachen werden vielleicht wirklich eine gewisse Substanz haben
Weil
Letztendlich
Überlegt euch mal
Selbst wenn ihr eine top aktuelle Software habt
Die einfach nur ein paar Wochen alt ist
Wenn ihr Pech habt
Irgendwo von irgendeiner
Dependency der Dependency der Dependency
So ein paar Sicherheitslücken gibt es immer
Die findest du immer
In irgendwelchen Dependencies
Aber wenn man die sich dann genauer anguckt
Sind die ja meistens so total
Relativ
Nicht total aber relativ irrelevant
Für das
Ja da hast du dann zum Beispiel
Doch eine recht hohe kritische
Sicherheit
Mit hohem Score eine Sicherheitslücke
Weil in irgendeiner Library beispielsweise
Input nicht richtig escaped wird
Ja für sich genommen ist das eine hohe
Sicherheitslücke aber
Nur weil du das als Dependency eingebunden hast
Heißt noch lange nicht
Dass deine Software ausnutzbar ist
Das ist potenziell ausnutzbar
Wenn einer diese Dependency
Ja verwendet und
Dort die Funktion aufruft
Mit den passenden Parametern
So das es passt
Wenn das nicht der Fall ist passiert dir nichts
Also die meisten Sachen haben überhaupt keine praktischen Auswirkungen
So wirklich auf null
Das du gar nichts hast bei so einem Scanner
Wirst du nicht haben
Weil selbst die aktuellste Software
Top auf top aktuellen Patch stand
Die haben Dependencies
Und die haben vielleicht eine Dependency
Guckt euch Javascript Anwendungen an
Machst du NPM Build
Dann hast du 500 Dependencies am Start
Irgendwas hat da immer
Irgendwie ist da immer was
Das muss nicht zwangsläufig schlecht sein
Um man
Dazu zu führen dass man es nicht verwenden kann
Naja da haben sie wieder Panik geschoben
Fand ich irgendwie wieder witzig
Wo ich mir gedacht habe
Übertreibts halt
Übertreibts halt nicht
Das wisst ihr was
Übrigens das ist auch so ein Ding
Was mich in der IT schon längere Zeit so ein bisschen wurmt
Ist
Auf der einen Seite
Sehr viel Wert gelegt auf
Ich muss das jetzt richtig sagen
Ich wollte nämlich gerade sagen
Sehr viel Wert gelegt auf Security
Und das ist ja eigentlich nicht das was ich sagen will
Das ist ja auch nicht falsch
Es wird sehr viel Wert
So meine ich das
Oder es wird zu viel Wert
Auf offensichtliche Sachen gelegt
Und die werden so kompliziert gemacht
Das offensichtliche Sachen
Enorm viel Zeit fressen
Aber meistens gar nicht
Die großen Probleme
Oder die großen Lücken verursachen
Scheiße formuliert
Nicht die großen Lücken verursachen
Die eigentlichen Leaks verursachen
Weil
Wenn es so Entscheidungen gibt
Wie zum Beispiel hier
Was Menschheit schreibt
Das jetzt jeder
Auch wenn es offensichtlich zu was gehört
Was nicht benutzt wird
Jeder Change
Von irgendwie einem Typ bewertet werden muss
Von einem Typ reviewed werden muss
Von einem anderen Typ nochmal abgenommen werden muss
Dann hast du
Ein halbes Team
Was sich eine Woche lang
Um 30 Security Probleme kümmert
Die sehr sehr sehr wahrscheinlich
Nie irgendein Problem
Verursachen werden
Weil das einfach nur drin ist
Nirgendwo aufgerufen wird
Und nicht mal verwendet wird
Im Umkehrschluss
Die Sachen die ein bisschen komplizierter sind
Wenn die Leute
Mit 40 ein Scan gefunden werden
Tja
Die bleiben liegen
Da macht sich keiner Gedanken drum
Das kenne ich nicht
Ja gut
Du hast ein Tool
Ein Tool löst das Problem aber nicht
Wenn du Vorschriften hast
Kosten-Nutzen-Verhältnis
Dass das trotzdem jedes einzelne geprüft werden muss
Obwohl man eigentlich schon weiß
Gar keine
Dass man zu sehr
Den offensichtlichen Sachen hinterher rennt
Nehmen wir mal
Nehmen wir mal ein Beispiel
Ja
Du hast einen Raum
Mit einer Tür und einem Fenster
Und es gibt jetzt
Es gibt jetzt die Ansage
Türen müssen immer verschlossen
Und maximal abgesichert sein
So
Und dann schließt du die Tür ab
Dann kommt das erste Security Review
Und sagt ha Moment
Das Schloss ist aber nicht sicher genug
Ok wird das Schloss ausgetauscht
Kommt das nächste Security Review und sagt
Das Material aus dem die Tür ist
Ist nicht ganz richtig
Neue Tür eingebaut
Security Review
Nächstes Security Review
Also wenn man da mit dem Bulldozer dagegen fährt
Dann reißt das ein an der Wand
Und es muss verstärkt werden
Wird die Tür verstärkt
Nächstes Security Review
Und dannactions
Dann Art es immer aus
Wo keiner dran denkt ist das der Raum ein Fenster
Hat im Erdgeschoss
Das sieht halt der Prozess nicht vor
Oder das sieht die Vorgaben nicht vor
Und das ist das
Wenn ihr euch manchmal
Die
Wie heißt das immer
Diese Post Mortem
Sachen anguckt
Die nach Datenleaks veröffentlicht wird
Das ist oftmals total
Simpler Shit
wodurch das zustande kommt, ja, von Entwicklern, die ihren USB-Stick verloren haben,
von alt weggeworfenen Laptops, von irgendwelchen offenen WLANs,
von irgendwelchen Google Drive Shares, wo alle Leute Zugriff drauf haben.
Das sind teilweise super simple, einfache Sachen.
Die haben das auf der einen Seite super krass vernagelt,
aber das Datenbank-Admin-Passwort, das muss natürlich im Klartext über Google Drive geshared werden,
weil wie soll man es dann doch sonst machen?
Ist jetzt natürlich nur ein Beispiel, aber ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Ich, ja, nehmen wir mal was anderes.
Beim alten Arbeitgeber hatten wir einmal so einen Security-Vorfall,
der ein bisschen brisanter gewesen ist,
und zwar, letztendlich wurde dort auch,
also ich meine, ich kann es euch nicht so sehr im Detail erzählen, aber grob,
im Prinzip wurde da auch alles abgesichert, ja.
Logins wurden protokolliert,
du konntest dich teilweise gar nicht mehr direkt netzwerktechnisch verbinden,
du konntest, also es war super, super krass secure mit vernagelt.
So, und wisst ihr, was am Ende passiert ist?
Wie es dazu gekommen ist, dass sie sich Ransomware-Shit für Windows-Kram eingefangen haben?
Es ist dazu gekommen,
wie gesagt, alles, alles super abgesichert und was ist passiert?
Sie hatten ein, jetzt haltet euch fest, sie hatten ein Windows,
wahrscheinlich 2008 oder so, was das noch da, oder 2012, was da drauf gelaufen ist,
äh, SFTP-Server,
wo eine externe Werbeagentur immer irgendwelche Sachen drüber eingeliefert hat.
Diese Werbeagentur wurde gehackermanned,
und dort haben die dann festgestellt, ach, gucke mal da,
von hier haben wir ja Zugriff drauf auf einen uralten Windows-SFTP-Server.
So, und ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wie es weiterging,
ich, wenn ich es wüsste, würde ich es euch auch nicht genau sagen,
zumindest dort auf dem SFTP-Server haben sie dann relativ schnell
irgendein altes, ungesichertes Account im ActiveDirect,
äh, Directory gefunden, der ist erst SFTP-Outdated,
ne, ich glaube, da war noch gar nicht mal, da hat es schon das SFTP auf Windows läuft.
Zumindest, im Endeffekt lief es dann darauf raus,
dass du über die Softwareverteilung vom Active Directory,
ähm, Keylogger und, und Passwort-Ram, Ram-Dumper verteilt hast.
Verteilt wurden.
Wohlgemerkt nur auf Windows-Notebooks.
Ich war glücklicherweise nicht betroffen.
Also, das ist ja der typische Fall von,
alles super verteilt,
vernagelt, so vernagelt,
dass man gar nicht mehr richtig arbeiten konnte,
aber das
war kein Problem. Und wisst ihr, warum
das kein Problem war?
Das ist jetzt aber Spekulation von mir,
das ist, das ist jetzt Spekulation
von mir, aber ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass das so ist.
Wisst ihr, warum das kein Problem war?
Weil man gesagt hat,
das ist ja kein Problem,
wir haben ja einen Vertrag mit dem Dienstleister,
dass die schon alles richtig machen.
Das passiert nämlich total oft,
dass man solche,
solche, solche, ähm,
vergessen, wie sich das nennt,
solche, solche,
Compliance-Verträge, oder so heißt das, glaube ich,
dass man solche, dass man solche Verträge macht mit seinen Dienstleistern,
was die alles einhalten müssen.
Die Netzwerke waren getrennt,
aber die konnten darauf zugreifen, weil die Sachen einliefern mussten.
Ja, dass man solche, solche Verträge macht mit Dienstleistern,
wo dann drinnen steht,
ja, wie, die und diese Vorgaben, haben wir das?
Ähm, dazu kann ich nix, nix im Detail erzählen,
da wird man nämlich finden, wo ich vorher gearbeitet hab.
Ähm, und diese, diese Vorgaben müsst ihr euch halten, und sowas.
Und natürlich sagen, klar,
klar, weil das war eine kleine Werbeagentur-Klitsche,
die sagen zu allem Ja und Ahm, ja?
Wenn da eine Bank zu denen kommt,
wie gesagt, war mal in der Bank, beim letzten Arbeitgeber,
wenn da eine Bank zu denen kommt,
und sagt, ey, Werbeagentur,
das und das müsst ihr erfüllen,
dann sagt die Werbeagentur,
aber selbstverständlich erfüllen wir das alles.
Die denken sich dann so nach dem Motto, ey, wisst ihr was?
Scheiß drauf.
Wir brauchen den Auftrag,
und wenn's in die Hose geht, sind wir eh am Arsch, so.
Was denken die sich dann?
Und insofern,
war das dann halt für'n Arsch.
Und wisst ihr, wie das Ganze aufgefallen ist?
Das ist ja noch viel, viel witziger gewesen.
Wie das Ganze aufgefallen ist?
Es ist nicht aufgefallen, etwa,
durch irgendwelche tollen Security,
AI-Scanner, oder,
hast du nicht gesehen?
Nein, es ist darauf, daran aufgefallen,
dass jemand sein
entschlüsseltes, müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen,
seine entschlüsselten Keypass-Passwörter
in einer Textdatei auf einem Windows-Laufwerk gefunden hat.
Und da hat er sich dann gedacht,
glücklicherweise war der so schlau damals, hat das gecheckt,
hat sich gedacht, also meine Keypass-Passwörter
gehören nicht im Klartext auf dem Windows-Share.
Und da hat er dann gesagt, sag mal, Leute,
wie kommen die denn da hin?
Und dann sind sie erst darauf gekommen,
dass es da Probleme gibt.
Und wisst ihr, was das Gute war?
Wisst ihr, was das Gute war?
Wir mit unseren Linux-Systemen und Linux-Notebooks
waren komplett raus.
Wir hatten die einzigen Server und die einzigen Rechner,
also Admin-Systeme,
die sicher waren in dieser Zeit.
Das ging dann so weit,
dass sogar kurzfristig
haben wir Ubuntu-USB-Sticks für alle angefertigt,
also für alle, die mussten,
Ubuntu-USB-Sticks,
und die mussten dann alle von den Ubuntu-USB-Sticks booten.
Leider hat das nicht so lange gehalten.
Leider hat es nicht so lange gehalten.
Und wisst ihr, was die Konsequenz daraus war,
die das Management abgeleitet hat?
Die Konsequenz ist so,
wir, ich habe es euch schon erzählt,
so wir, dass ihr mir das nicht glauben werdet,
aber die Konsequenz daraus,
die man abgeleitet hat, ist,
Windows Defender auf allen Servern zu installieren,
inklusive Linux.
Damit sowas nicht mehr vorkommen kann.
Das ist kein Witz.
1 zu 1.
Oh, sorry, nicht Windows Defender,
Microsoft Advanced Threat Protection
nennt sich das.
Das ist Windows Defender.
Die haben sich daraus abgeleitet,
weil das kacke konfiguriert war,
und Windows Shit,
dass auf allen Servern inklusive Linux
Windows Defender installiert werden muss.
Und das Ding hat so krasse Probleme gemacht,
nachdem es drauf war.
Laufen hat es irgendeinen Shit.
Und das Beste ist an Windows Defender,
Microsoft kann Windows Defender Updates ausrollen,
Virensignaturen Updates ausrollen,
die eigentliche Defender Updates sind.
Also du erlaubst,
du musst ja Microsoft erlauben,
damit es funktioniert.
Also du musst ja
für den Windows Defender
Virensignaturen Updates verteilen,
beziehungsweise freischalten,
dass die sich bei Microsoft abrufen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie es genau funktioniert.
Zumindest muss das Ding sich regelmäßig
Windows Defender Virensignaturen Updates ziehen.
Und Microsoft verpackt
in Virensignaturen,
nicht nur Virensignaturen,
sondern Windows Defender Updates.
Und so kam es dann auf einmal,
dass es Linux File Server gab,
die immer 5% CPU Last hatten,
nichts wildes.
Und auf einmal sind die immer auf 95%
CPU Last gelaufen.
Kam dann raus, ach so, ja,
die letzte Virensignatur enthielte
ein Windows Defender Update.
Das hat einen kleinen Bug, das verursacht jetzt halt
unter Linux super viel CPU Last.
So ein Schrott, Alter.
Das ist halt wieder so der typische Fall von
blindem Aktionismus gewesen.
Ja.
Das,
das passiert ja oftmals.
Umso zugenagelter was ist,
umso abpackender
es ist zu arbeiten,
umso mehr werden Wege gesucht,
es zu umgehen.
Das habe ich irgendwie aus Versehen hier gerade
das kleiner gemacht.
Bestes Beispiel dafür ist doch
Passwortrichtlinien.
Wenn es Passwortrichtlinien gibt,
dann muss ein Passwort
mindestens 20
Stellen lang sein, mindestens
ein Sonderzeichen enthalten, mindestens
eine Zahl und das und das.
Das wird dann so kompliziert,
dass die Leute sich das nicht mehr merken können.
Was machen die Leute dann?
Die Leute machen dann sowas hier.
Guckt, sowas kommt dann als Passwort raus.
Sorry, sorry.
Groß, groß,
Groß- und Kleinschreibung.
Da kommt dann sowas als Passwort raus.
Weil, ja gut,
erfüllt die Passwortrichtlinien.
Kann man sich gerade noch so merken.
Übertriebene
Passwortrichtlinien sorgen für genau so
einen Blödsinn.
Wie bist du hergekommen? Über Youtube oder auf der
Twitch-Empfehlung?
Hier in den Hacken.
Hackback Edition.
Okay, können wir uns angucken.
Aber nicht jetzt.
Vielleicht das da?
Ist das das Richtige?
Komm, wir gucken aber nicht jetzt.
Das ist zu lange.
Wenn ich mir eine Stunde...
Ich hab mal vergessen,
wie die heißt.
Wo es quasi
eine Challenge ist, ein Passwort
zu finden, das
den immer komplexer werdenden Anforderungen
genügt. Wie hieß das denn?
Passwort... Passwort Game?
Ne, keine Ahnung.
Wisst ihr was gut ist, Leute?
Morgen
ist Freitag. Morgen nehme ich was auf.
Morgen Mittag.
Kann ich Samstag hochladen?
Dann müssen wir endlich am Wochenende
mal ein bisschen Technikzeug streamsen wieder.
Ich hatte einfach keine Gehirnkapazität
in letzter Zeit.
Morgen ist Read-Only-Friday.
Wirklich? Passwort Game?
Ja, das mein ich.
Genau das mein ich.
Please choose a password.
Okay. Erstes
Rule.
Must include
special character.
Digits in your password
must add up to 25.
Kannst dann sowas machen wie
irgendwie...
Ich kann jetzt nicht einfach
machen 23, also muss ich jetzt...
Boah, das ist halt...
krasses Zeug.
Ja, das meinte ich genau.
Was ist Read-Only-Friday?
Tatlab?
Aber das freut mich,
dass morgen Freitag ist. Dann gibt's wieder
Bream Video und
MMO Kreiselgrind.
Read-Only-Friday heißt, dass es keine
Changes gibt. Ja, das ist eine gute Idee.
In dem letzten Laden, wo ich gearbeitet hab, gab's tatsächlich
nie Changes am Freitag.
Weil die nicht wollten, dass dann was ist.
Was echt eine sinnvolle
Policy war, fand ich.
Find ich immer noch.
Naja. Gut, Leute.
Es ist jetzt gleich
Bed-Getime. 22 Uhr.
Ihr wisst, Boomer werden früher
müde. Aber
Boomer brauchen zum Glück nicht so viel Schlaf.
Deswegen geh ich jetzt pennen. Morgen
bin ich kurz vor 7 wieder
am Start. Allerdings nicht auf Twitch.
Sondern auf der Arbeit.
Remote. Homeoffice beste.
Und dann Nachmittag.
Nachmittag wahrscheinlich
Stream oder ich nehm
erstes Video auf oder umgedreht. Mal gucken.
Michael
50 Milliarden. Schön, dass du da warst.
Ich hab dich lange nicht im Stream gesehen oder
ich hab einfach nicht richtig hingeguckt.
Letzten schon gefragt. Wo ist er denn?
Und wo ich mich auch gefragt hab ist
Wo ist denn eigentlich
in letzter Zeit der Chainlore?
Nicht, dass der temporär
gebannt ist oder so wieder.
Kann ja bei ihm immer sein.
Den hab ich auch schon ne Weile nicht mehr gesehen.
Chat.
Kann das sein?
Das wir komplett
Mod
Modlos waren. Der Max war
am Anfang mal da. Hab ich gesehen.
Ah, da ist er. Ne, waren wir nicht.
Max. Max ist wahrscheinlich immer noch da.
Modcheck.
Es fehlen
einige. Ne, die fehlen mir nicht.
Weil der Chainlore
spammt manchmal auch sehr fragwürdige ASCII
Dinger, wo man ihn dann timeouten muss für.
Modcheck. Modcheck
fehlgeschlagen.
Du stehst zur Verfügung.
Zur Zeit seh ich nicht, dass
wir mehr Mods brauchen.
Und es ist gut zu wissen,
wenn wir
neue Mods brauchen, mach ich das meistens
so, dass ich im
Modchannel, im Discord
frage, wen sich die anderen
Modgis gut als Modgift
vorstellen können. Du bist ja auch schon relativ
aktiv hier. Ich meine 565
Messages. Einfach den ganzen
Chat zum Mod machen. Fyfet.
Das ist das Gegenteil. Das ist inverted
Fyfet. Einmal pro
Stream. Es geht gar nicht darum, ob ich das
erlauben will oder nicht. Wenn ihr irgendwelche
komischen
Ihr wisst, was Zeugs postet.
Kann ich jetzt nicht einfach
stehen lassen.
Der Channel hat schon
Gachi Roll Aski
Dinger gepostet, wo man deutlich mehr gesehen hat.
Mit der Taktik kommst du
bei mir nicht weit. Das ist die Taktik, die ich früher
teilweise auch mal verfolgt habe. So nach
dem Motto, wenn man was werden wollte, hat
man besonders offensiv gesagt, dass man das gar nicht
werden will. Und dann
aber das ist halt keine gute Taktik.
Ich bin sogar mal
in der Grundschule mit dieser
Taktik fast Klassensprecher geworden.
Ich weiß nicht, was mich
geritten hat, dass ich mich
wählen lassen wollte zum Klassensprecher.
Und
ich habe die Taktik
gefahren, weiß ich noch.
Ich habe die Taktik gefahren so nach dem Motto,
also ich würde das ja voll gut machen, aber
ich will sowas gar nicht machen.
Wer will dann sowas machen? Wer will
dann Klassensprecher sein? Da muss man sich
Sachen kümmern. Ich will das überhaupt nicht machen.
Ich könnte das sicherlich ganz gut machen.
Aber ich will das gar nicht.
Und dann wäre ich fast Klassensprecher geworden.
Zum Glück
bin ich es nicht geworden, Alter.
Alles klar, Leute.
Wir sehen uns.
Bis denn.
Bis morgen Mittag. Macht's gut. See you.